[Musique]
geny infos va facci ita tirage brazza
vote sont deux chefs la haussier dans
des restaurants montréalais
ils ont une vision originale de la
cuisson sur le green washing aux jeunes
lancé me suis inspiré des cultures
culinaires sud américaines et asiatiques
ils nous font découvrir des brochettes
différentes beaucoup de culture d'autres
à la montée des grillades fait partie de
la vie alors juste l'odeur du barbecue
rassemblement on va commencer que le
coeur de boeuf aujourd'hui à khimki
marinade péruvienne à un petit sco même
si le coeur de boeuf est généralement
disponibles dans nos épiceries
il est peu utilisé dans nos plats mais
fort appréciée dans plusieurs cultures
culinaires ça se coupe à la brosse rick
le très bon sens oui dans notre culture
c'est parti là ont cessé une partie
qu'on va respecter on essaie de vraiment
minimiser la perte mais ces partis qui
sont écrit très bien pour le goûter
parce qu'il ferait on peut tout mangé
cru pendant longtemps qu'on sait où
douze premiers note votre protéines
aussi puis là ça vous dit quoi là la
bouche et que j'avais prise est parfait
surtout goûter mais c'est bon oui comme
un steak commencé il n'y a pas de goût
trop fort c'est super succès le quart
que j'aurais pensé qu' une partie de
filet ou à douala pour préparer la
marinade anti-tout qu on utilise un pied
mélangeur ou amorti et non dans la
culture sur l'appel cette dame dont le
nom marina de tous nos recettes
on vient les l'état remet donc les
écraser au mortier justement puis ça
fait sortir le jeu sans trop le travail
on était gros du sel ainsi que de l'aïe
on regarde aussi la peau de l'aïe
il ya beaucoup de parfums en faisant
sauter ça vient enrober sa vie caresser
d'audience après avoir ajouté une poudre
poivre citron des cadres des fines
herbes et des petits poivrons doux vendu
sous le nom de sweet rucks le mélange
restera vingt-quatre heures au frigo
à moins que l'on soit pressé oui un
petit truc on peut prendre du citron ou
l'achat d'ananas on va le marquer juste
pour une heure alors les enzymes de la
nano va juste arrivé pour attendrir
casser les films pour bien les prêts
nier la viande de la marinade pas trop
liquide
il existe quelques techniques je vais le
passer il ya nous sommes à saint-anselme
à se servir pour m mais ce serait le
même principe pour nous prouver qu'elle
vient quelle occasion
n'importe quel bien sûr qu'il ya des
gens à la base plus rude et d'autres
plus tendres mais à la fin pour bien
faire rentrer les savoirs on veut
vraiment venir massé et pour obtenir une
cuisson uniforme ont fait opérer la
viande
une vingtaine de minutes à la
température de la pièce avant de la
placer sur le grill
si on sort la viande du frigo mais aux
querelles et à 4,5 ou à 6 degrés et on
va la mettre à haute température
l'extérieur cuit mal intérieur reste
froid donc on peut biaiser la cuisson
mais vaut-il mieux utiliser des
brochettes de bois ou de métal le bois
c'est plus pratique ton peut le trouver
partout mais le métal c'est ça tape
longtemps et ça aussi à chaleur du
barbecue
je range étal à l'autre c'est de là
qu'ils sont aussi je vous ai
confectionné une baguette mais là on
fait la seule vraiment là aussi avec ce
travers les strain bris pour faire
ressortir de savoir le serait on fait
juste plus de frapper un peu juste pour
faire sur les jupes et les essences
naturelles
alors problème prochaine brochette on va
faire recette à la mortadelle un de mes
crocs coach préfet jambon italien jambon
italien
pourquoi ça va être préféré c'est gros
comme moi puis c'est bon goût alors ici
on a des figues sèches
alors jusqu'où perdu après avoir fait ça
on va les mettre en brèche est alors aux
promenades elle fait juste la même chose
pour gagner alterné modèle toi olive
oliva et petites tomates séchées
s'éteint alors on voit pas ça souvent ce
mariage de l'un non mais là c'est
vraiment un sucré salé
alors quand vous prend le boucher chaque
bouchée des différents chaque phase doit
être bien grillées c'est pour ça que le
mot ni âme soeur le lam hôtel ritz et le
crostis heures qui s'adonnent à
l'extérieur à cause du gros la vie
devient tout conscient qu'à l'inter - le
rsa c'est la fiesta là êtes vous content
je suis pas content la russie la
maternelle du pas bon quand c'est tantôt
le 40 15 les cardigans
versez
[Musique]